بالانتقال الآن إلى قصة مزعجة
من الضفة الغربية ، قُتلت فتاة فلسطينية تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
برصاص
جنود إسرائيليين خلال غارة في
بلدة جنين بالضفة الغربية يوم الأحد ،
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إن إطلاق النار كان
غير مقصود ويقول نيران إسرائيلية  تم
استهداف مسلح ، لقد كان
هذا عامًا مميتًا بشكل خاص لكل من
الفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين.
قصة مأساوية للغاية بدأنا نسمعها لأول مرة عن هذه
الفتاة الصغيرة التي قُتلت في وقت سابق من هذا
الصباح كانت تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا تدعى
جانيس أ كارن وعائلتها
أخبر عمها شبكة CNN أن ما حدث
الليلة الماضية كان هناك غارة عسكرية إسرائيلية
على جانين هذا  في شمال
الضفة الغربية ، أصبح هذا
حدثًا معتادًا خاصة في العام الماضي
، حيث استهدف الجيش الإسرائيلي الجماعات المسلحة
وخاصة في  مثل
جنين وعائلتها تقول إنه بعد بدء المداهمة
وبدأوا في سماع
إطلاق نار كثيف ، صعدت جينا إلى سطح
بنايتها لترى ما يجري ،
وهذا شيء غالبًا ما نرى
الفلسطينيين سوف يصورون هذه المداهمات
فور حدوثها.  ثم قالت العائلة
إنه بعد أن غادر الجنود المنطقة
صعدوا إلى السطح
وهنا وجدوا جنة ميتة قالوا
إنها أصيبت أربع مرات الآن في
الدقائق القليلة الماضية فقط تلقينا
البيان الرسمي من الجيش الإسرائيلي الذي
يعترف  أن جنودهم هم من
قتلوا جنة ، يقولون إنهم قالوا
أثناء المداهمة إن المشتبه بهم ألقوا
متفجرات وأطلقوا النار بكثافة على
الجنود ، بما في ذلك من أسطح المنازل
، قالوا إنهم يعتقدون أن الفتاة
كانت على سطح بالقرب من سقف آخر
حيث يمكن أن يكون مسلحًا.  قالوا
بعد تحقيق أولي أنه تم
تحديد أن الفتاة التي قتلت
أصيبت بنيران غير مقصودة
استهدفت مسلحين على سطح
المنطقة التي تم إطلاق القوة منها
الآن ، علق وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي بيني
غانتس على هذا الحادث في
الواقع قبل بيان الجيش الإسرائيلي الذي
يعترف بأنهم هم
الذين قتلوا جينا ، استمع
إلى ما قاله
أولاً لقد أعربت عن حزني لها
الموت بالنسبة لأي حالة وفاة لشخص
غير متورط في الإرهاب ، إذا
كان هذا هو الحال بالفعل ، كان هذا النشاط
يتعلق باعتقال المشتبه بهم وعمليات إطلاق
النار والتورط في
تنظيمات إرهابية بهدف قتل
إسرائيليين أثناء الحادث
تم إطلاق نيران كثيفة على القوات
وألقيت متفجرات وزجاجات مولوتوف
ردا على ذلك ردت القوات على
النار على مصادر إطلاق
النار دفاعا عن النفس
الآن دعا الفلسطيني ورئيس الوزراء
محمد في الأمم المتحدة
للتحقيق في هذا الحادث ووضع إسرائيل
على القائمة السوداء سألت الإسرائيليين.
العسكري ما إذا كان سيكون هناك أي نوع
من إجراءات المتابعة القانونية يقولون
أنهم ما زالوا يحققون في
حادثة ديلاني